- When I first heard the
idea of a turntable ferry,
I assumed it was an early design
before anyone figured out
how to do ferries properly.
A modern cross-river ferry
is built with the cabin at the side
so cars can drive on and drive off
without having to awkwardly reverse.
So, I figured a turntable
ferry like this one
is going to be a prototype solution
before anyone figured out how
to put the cabin at the side.
Instead of having the cars reverse off,
you turn the whole car deck around.
And yes, that does happen here,
but the real reason for the turntable
is more clever than that.
And there's only one of them
left anywhere in the world,
here in western Scotland,
over the sea to Skye.
- There's been a ferry here
since the 1700s, people say;
a vehicle ferry certainly since the 1930s.
This particular ferry has
been here since the 1980s,
and it was operated by a
man called Roddy MacLeod.
And when the tolls were
removed from the Skye Bridge,
he felt probably that the
ferry's time was up, really,
'cause you could get across
the bridge for nothing,
so who would pay to go on the ferry?
So, the local community
banded together and thought,
"We can't have this.
"Not having the ferry
is a social experiment
"we don't want to be involved in."
So, a little group of folk got
together and saved the ferry
and brought it into
community ownership,
which it still is today.
- There is quite a strong current.
The current can be up to
nine knots in the strait,
but that's exceptional.
Current and wind together
can make things interesting.
The ferry is very seldom
pointing in the direction
it's actually going.
Because of the wind and
because of the tide,
we often have to set the boat
going in a different direction
to allow us to get to where we want to go.
- The water here is tidal
and the current is fast.
Simple ferry designs are great
if you've got steady water
that's always at the same height.
Your boat arrives, puts
down a ramp to the shore,
and the cars can drive on and off.
But if the water's tidal, well,
that ramp could need to go
three or four metres up or down
depending on the time of
day, so the only way it works
is if you build infrastructure
on the riverbanks:
floating pontoons and large ramps
that give the cars enough
room to drive up and down.
That's far too big and expensive
for somewhere like this,
so the obvious solution is a slipway:
a boat ramp, a long gentle
approach to the water.
In a lot of places, that does work.
Sail up to the water's edge, drop a ramp,
and everyone stays dry no
matter the water's height.
But that means you need
a long, long slipway
and, importantly, your boat
needs to be lined up straight.
Here in this narrow channel,
the current can be so
strong that isn't possible.
Even if you could line up
straight reliably,
you can only tie the
boat off at the front,
so the back's probably
going to swing out a bit.
So, what you want to do is
what a passenger ferry does:
pull up alongside the slipway
and let people get off sideways.
Great for people, not so useful for cars.
And that's where the turntable comes in.
- The turntable is a remarkable piece
of Victorian engineering.
It was based on the old
railway turntable system.
Cars could come onto
the boat from any jetty
at any state of the tide
to then be turned round
and be able to drive off.
Usually, it's two, but
one person can turn it.
A lot of oil and grease is expended
in keeping it as
smooth as we can!
The way that the boat is designed,
it draws virtually no
draught at all forward
and it's only four-and-a-half
feet at the stern,
so it can come alongside
in very shallow water.
That was the part of the design
that makes them so versatile.
Very, very, very rare
indeed that we can't work.
It would have to be an
exceptionally low tide.
Before the invention of
the roll-on/roll-off ferry,
these were the original
roll-on/roll-off ferries.
- Now, there's been a
bridge across to Skye
north of here since 1995,
so these days this is
mostly used just by locals
and as a tourist attraction in the summer.
But if you are in this area, well,
I'd recommend taking a diversion
and driving across this way
because there's only
one place in the world
where you can drive off
a turntable like this.
Thank you very much!